[Música]
y en directo a conectamos con lisboa la
capital de portugal allí empezó la
conferencia de la onu sobre los océanos
en la inauguración el secretario general
de naciones unidas afirmó que existe una
emergencia oceánica hasta el primero de
julio políticos científicos y activistas
hablarán de cómo gestionar los océanos
de manera sostenible esto en un momento
crítico en el que el mundo intentará
reforzar sus acciones para lograr los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible antes
del 2030 para eso conectamos con nuestra
enviada especial marina colorado marina
buenas noches para usted y cuéntenos
cuál es el propósito de la conferencia
de los océanos y quiénes participan en
ella
pues el propósito de esta segunda
conferencia de los océanos es
principalmente pasar de las decisiones
tomadas en la reunión de 2017 a las
acciones es decir encontrar soluciones
concretas a los urgentes problemas a los
que se enfrenta el océano y
financiamiento para llevarlas a cabo
para esto se reúnen unos 7.000
participantes de lisboa hasta el viernes
con charlas encuentros y eventos donde
unir esfuerzos desde el ámbito político
pero sobre todo desde el sector privado
donde está el dinero para implementarlas
y es que el océano es el protagonista
real del cambio climático es quien
absorbe un cuarto de las emisiones de
co2 que emitimos y el 90% del exceso de
calor que resulta de las diferentes
emisiones de los demás gases de efecto
invernadero además de regular las épocas
de lluvia justamente por eso es quien
más sufren sus efectos de echo antión
antonio guterres del secretario general
de la onu dijo que estamos ante una
emergencia oceánica a pesar de cubrir el
70% de la superficie del planeta
conocemos y hemos invertido más en
explorar la luna esto pese a que más de
mil millones de personas dependen
directamente del mar para subsistir cada
año entre 8 y 11 millones de toneladas
llegan al océano desde la tierra y en
2050 eso hará que el peso del plástico
será mayor que el de los peces un 80 por
ciento de las aguas residuales llega sin
tratar al mar y el calentamiento del
agua ha causado la muerte del 50% de los
corales en los últimos 50 años así que
como ven muchos problemas así que se
necesitan muchas soluciones
marina y que se puede esperar que ocurra
en esta conferencia en lisboa serán
medidas vinculantes o no
precisamente el presidente de kenia
uhuru kenyatta dijo en su discurso de
apertura de la conferencia que no pueden
seguir adquiriendo compromisos que luego
no se vayan a cumplir quien se ha
cumplido en este campo es colombia que
con ocho años de antelación conseguirá
el objetivo de proteger el 30 por ciento
de sus océanos que estaba previsto para
el 2030 más allá de las fronteras
nacionales espera este año un tratado
sobre las aguas internacionales que
están sobreexplotadas infra protegidas
en ese sentido el secretario general de
la onu alegó que el egoísmo de algunos
países refiriéndose a los más
industrializados está ralentizando ese
proceso se esperan avances en el acuerdo
sobre plásticos que se anunció en
febrero que si es legalmente vinculante
pero por ahora sigue en fase de
negociación y no estará listo antes de
finales de 2024 así que está claro que
una sola cumbre no va a definir el
futuro de la lucha climática o de la
defensa del océano pero si va sumando en
los esfuerzos según el enviado especial
de la onu para los océanos peter
thompson las cumbres y conferencias
sirven sobre todo para que los mismos
países y organizaciones tengan un
mecanismo de responsabilidad por el que
medir sus acciones a lo largo de una
conferencia tras otra y además recordó
que lo más urgente es el financiamiento
ya que de los 17 objetivos de desarrollo
sostenibles estipulados por la onu para
el 2030 el que se refiere al océano es
el que menos presupuesto tiene así que
hay bastantes cosas por hacer en esta
conferencia hasta el viernes veremos qué
sale de esta declaración de lisboa
como usted lo dice ya veremos que sale
de la declaración gracias marina y
nosotros seguimos aquí en directo
américa